[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en ginebra
la alta comisionada las naciones unidas
para los derechos humanos michelle
bachelet entregó su informe sobre la
situación en afganistán y denunció en
cumplimiento de las promesas del talibán
al asumir el poder tras el retiro de las
tropas de eeuu también manifestó su
preocupación porque las mujeres han sido
excluidas de los espacios públicos en
menos de un mes el ministro de educación
superior ordenó el fin de las clases
mixtas permitidas hasta ahora en las
universidades nos acompaña maria teresa
palacios ella es directora del grupo de
derechos humanos de la universidad del
rosario y doctora en derecho maría
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 la organización de naciones
unidas aseguró que en afganistán se
puede llegar a una catástrofe
generacional en temas de educación qué
quiere decir la onu con esta advertencia
además le pregunto qué pasará entonces
con las mujeres en las universidades y
en general qué pasará con los derechos
de las mujeres en ese país
buen dia raúl muchas gracias por la
invitación si realmente creo que para
quienes consideramos que los derechos
humanos deben ser
promovidos y sobre todo respetados en
muchos países del mundo es una gran
preocupación una gran preocupación
porque los derechos de las mujeres ya en
el último informe que se venía
presentando sobre los derechos en
afganistán se encontraban con una muy
baja participación no solamente en los
espacios públicos sino también incluso
en espacios privados de otro lado pues
la exclusión de estos espacios en
educación preocupan gravemente porque
claramente conducen a la mujer a una
revictimización a que se agudiza aún más
su situación de vulnerabilidad pero que
se recrudezca asimismo también los actos
de discriminación en contra de ellas y
es que la o no busca en ginebra- un
mayor consenso global para responder a
la crisis afgana en la sesión 48 del
consejo de derechos humanos que se
desarrolla con qué medidas concretas
podrían responder los países
pues básicamente yo creo que hay mucha
expectativa sobre la necesidad de que
haya un mecanismo de supervisión un
mecanismo de los que digamos el consejo
de derechos humanos dispone para la
supervisión de países y ahí tenemos el
mecanismo precisamente de un mandato por
país aunque también podrían desplegarse
mecanismos como las comunicaciones por
violaciones a derechos humanos entonces
pienso yo que el mundo mira con
expectativa la posibilidad de que pueda
haber un seguimiento puntual al caso de
la violación de derechos humanos en
afganistán y pensaría que el más
apropiado podría ser un mandato por país
para que haya además visita en terreno
al país en el lugar de los hechos y
poder constatar y documentar un poco y
el marco de las violaciones a derechos
humanos y además el incremento de la
vulnerabilidad los derechos no solamente
de las mujeres sino también de los niños
de las niñas porque sabemos que la
situación de derechos humanos en
afganistán es multidimensional y
multinivel bachelet también urgió al
consejo de derechos humanos a crear un
mecanismo que monitor de forma más
profunda la situación de las libertades
fundamentales en afganistán cómo
funcionaría esto
básicamente ese mecanismo es lo que
hablábamos hace un momento y se trata de
un mecanismo de supervisión es un
mandato por país es un mandato que hace
parte de los procedimientos especiales
donde un grupo de expertos digamos es
designado para hacer una observación
puntual a las violaciones de derechos
humanos en el territorio y tienen
adicionalmente por la facultad de poder
ir al terreno a hacer esas supervisiones
cuál es la dificultad de estos
mecanismos que la mayor parte de estos
mecanismos pues tienen o requieren más
bien de la voluntariedad del estado de
poderles permitir ingresar en territorio
porque de todas maneras todos estos
mecanismos de las naciones unidas
cuentan con la soberanía del estado y
respetan la soberanía del estado para
poder funcionar les digamos que ahí
encontramos una limitación desde el
punto de vista que si el gobierno
talibán claramente no se compromete con
el cumplimiento de los derechos como lo
dijo pues en su etapa electoral pues
esto sí podría haber agudizados los
riesgos en materia de no solamente
acceso a los derechos de las mujeres y
de muchas personas que los padecen sino
también de que el mecanismo de
supervisión puede hacer realmente eficaz
vamos a ver entonces qué pasa a maria
tereza y ojalá así sea eficaz para
proteger los derechos humanos en
afganistán tras la toma del talibán del
poder de ese país maría teresa palacios
directora del grupo de derechos humanos
de la universidad de rosario en colombia
más doctora en derecho hasta que
llegamos en cinco minutos con por el día
de hoy nos vemos en una próxima
oportunidad hasta pronto
[Música]